i do have
uh important chats early on i want to be
a cool dad
no no no no no one wants cool parents
we're just we're going to be boring
and don't forget why you're doing it
yeah we need something in our lives
that's bigger than us something that
will
outlive us carry on after we've gone we
will all right
we have loads of plastic bags in our
kitchen drawer
do try to be patient
never going to find a kid eddie's gone
you're kidding she only come on the site
yesterday
they go so quickly it's like trying to
get glastonbury tickets
and you should be prepared for a bit of
disappointment
hmm
don't overthink it what am i supposed to
do with a boy jase
society already fills him with
confidence how can i compete with
society jase it's
bloody everywhere do do practice
your parenting skills it's just a bit of
football in the park with some kids
football
it's pretty football that's good that's
fine
don't lose your sense of humor happy
yeah and why have you got your head in
your hands
huh and do
always be there for each other
you